Brace yourself and bear with me. I'm
going to try to digest 14 centuries
here. Of course, it all starts with
Muhammad. For about a decade, Muhammad
was a preacher in Mecca. The Meccan
verses are the ones that the apologists
love to quote because they have a veneer
of tolerance to them. That was because
he was completely outnumbered. And then
the pivotal moment of course comes in
Hijra, the migration. And then in
Medina, he became a political
technically a political warlord. To me
the genius of Muhammad I often say this
is that he took the tribal mores of his
time 7th century Arabia which was
immensely tribal and he deified them. He
rearticulated them through a theological
paradigm. The tribe was no longer blood
can it was the believers. It was the um
you win more because you go to heaven
and you get the the 72 you know
dark eyed blackeyed virgins created for
the express purpose to gratify Allah's
favorites in perpetuity. This man's
entire appeal is to appeal to the basist
instinct of his followers by allowing
them to kill and plunder and rape and at
the same time feel like you're holy for
doing that.
Hi everyone. Welcome to the very first
episode of my Islam and the West series
on the Yas with Muhammad podcast. Thank
you so much for joining us here today
and for hopefully listening through the
rest of this series which is going to
focus on, as the title would suggest,
Islam and the West. So, we're going to
start at the very beginning today. Today
we're starting with a very important man
who I'm very grateful who was able to be
able to start off this podcast series
with me, Raymond Ibraim. So Raymond is
an expert in Islamic history and
doctrine. He is widely he is a widely
published expert in the Middle East and
Islam. He's the author of many books
including sword and simar 14 centuries
of war between Islam and the west. So
exactly the topics that we're going to
be talking about in this series.
Ibrahim's dual background born and
raised in the US by Egyptian parents who
were born and raised in the Middle East
has provided him with unique advantages
from equal fluency in English and Arabic
to an equal understanding of the Western
and Middle Eastern mindsets. So you can
see why I said if I had a magic wand, I
couldn't have conjured up a better guest
to start off this series. right on the
ground floor to give us a history of
Asam. How did it start and to bring us
as much as possible to here to today and
to show us all of the connecting
threads. Raymond, welcome. Welcome to
the first episode of Islam in the West.
>> Um, thank you Yasmin. I'm very happy to
be with you. Sounds like a good endeavor
you got going.
>> Yes, I hope so. And thank you again for
being here with us to start us off. Um,
so I was reading through your book, the
one that I just mentioned, Sword in the
Centaur,
and you did a lot of unpacking Islam, as
the the um subtitle says, 14 centuries
of war between Islam and the West. But,
um, what I want you to do today is give
us as much as you can, as concise as
possible, a history of a snap. So people
see what's happening today in the West,
but they may not recognize these common
threads that I was talking about, these
very deepseated threads leading back
1400 years. So I'm hoping you can tell
us the history of how Islam started
specifically referring to Hijra and what
that means and why it's so significant
to the spread of Islam.
>> Sure. Uh so brace yourself and bear with
me. So I'm going to try to digest 14
centuries here and um of course it all
starts with Muhammad and that's where
the hijra comes from. Hijra of course is
year one in the Islamic calendar and it
corresponds to the year u in the western
calendar or the Christian calendar uh
622.
Um but of course you have to you're you
can't just add it together because they
go by the lunar calendar as well. At any
rate, Muhammad uh before that point had
been preaching
>> and the word hijra, the word hijra means
>> a migrate to migrate basically.
>> Um so before that event for about a
decade, Muhammad was a preacher in in
Mecca. Um and of course this is a
polytheistic time. The Arabs uh
overwhelmingly were what you would call
pagans. Um and his message was not
wellreceived. uh and this is if you want
to know what he said it's basically in
the Quran but it is what's considered
the Mecca phase and unfortunately the
Quran is not uh outlined in a
chronological order so you have to
actually have some understanding which
one is Mecca which one comes later
Medina but at any rate the mechan verses
are the ones that the apologists love to
quote because they have a a veneer of
tolerance to them they're the ones where
Muhammad talks about you have your
religion I have mine there is no
coercion in religion etc etc. Um and so
that's Muhammad during Mecca. Now of
course that was because he was
completely outnumbered. He didn't the
only his in in those 10 years the only
people who believed in his prophethhood
were relatives close relatives and the
number over a decade didn't grow to
maybe more than a hundred. So he was
outnumbered and he was in no position to
actually go on the offensive and again
that's why you get those verses. And
then the pivotal moment of course comes
Hijra the migration where he's invited
to uh Ythreb which we know today as
Medina you know the city of light and
he's invited there. It's you know there
were a lot of Jews living there as well
as Arabs. And the long and short of it
is he becomes a political authority. So
that's the shift. He went from an
itinerant um sort of harmless preacher
in Mecca and then in Medina he became a
political technically a political
warlord. Okay. And this is where um so
now you now in Medina a lot of the
revelations as they call them of the
Quran the verses that came to him at
that time these now become more
militant. Okay. And um and they
ultimately culminate with allout
offensive warfare against pagans and and
also Christians and Jews. Keep in mind
when he went to Mecca uh I'm sorry,
Medina dur after the Hijra uh there was
a covenant that he actually created with
those people the Jews and the Arabs and
it was a sort of uh you know a pact of
cooperation but eventually uh as he got
stronger that was also abregated and he
turned on them and of course we know of
all the sort of horrific attacks on the
Jews the Beni thing whom he had
beheaded. Um so the point of the hijra
is and the blueprint is it's a migration
it's a consolidation it's a growth of
power and slowly you spread out so once
he had acquired enough power in in
Medina then he went on the offensive so
now you get the verses uh the most
famous of which in Arabic's uh a which
means the sword verse and that's 95
which basically it just uh it says you
will lay and wait for the polytheists,
the idoltors, the pagans wherever you
can find them and kill them and besiege
them and take them hostage. Okay. So
that was uh according to a lot of Muslim
exedites that verse alone abregated
something over a hundred peaceful verses
because also Muslims go by this
abrogation of course is
is this idea that the verses the
revelations that were revealed to
Muhammad over all those years the reason
they contradict what you know we already
pointed out some say you know there's
tolerance and you you have your religion
and I have my religion and then you have
these other ones which say no call out
warfare. Uh another pivotal one is 929
which says fight the people of the book
who Muslims uh understand to be Jews and
Christians the scriptuaries as they call
them until they pay Jiza which means
tribute and live essentially a secondass
very and the verse says and live and
they have to pay tribute and feel
themselves humbled. Okay. So and that's
that's a whole other thing which is you
know that's the bedrock idea behind what
we call dimitude or the dimma where you
can live as a Christian or Jew under
Islamic uh rule but you are at best a
secondass citizen you don't have much
rights etc we can get into that later
but so all of that is what comes out
during the the Medina phase the later
phase and because it's the later phase
it's believed to have abregated all the
earlier ones okay and then the earlier
ones are seen as essentially um you know
when Muslims find themselves in that
position then they can actually adhere
to those verses. Oh, if you're a Muslim
living in America and obviously you're
outnumbered, then you become like
Muhammad during in Mecca and now you can
preach peace and you can uh you know use
that blueprint. And I'll share with you
in a a funny anecdote. Um when I worked
at the Library of Congress, which had a
significant Muslim population because of
course Washington DC is very diverse and
multicultural. Uh there was a Muslim man
who I worked very closely with and you
know we had a kind of tense but also
friendly relationship because he knew I
knew what he was all about and it was
kind of funny but um we would have I at
one point we had this entire I I said
what I just told you okay about the
abrogation and this and that and because
he kept insisting no no the Quran has
the good verses and we need to follow
them always and then when I explained to
him all this and saying well what about
abregation what about the militant
verses etc and I said well those verses
only apply to Mecca when you're weak and
outnumbered. So he got frustrated and
said, "Well, I live in America. That is
Mecca."
>> So of course his point was, "Yeah, I'm
I'm employing those verses because I'm
in that situation, I'm outnumbered, I'm
weak." And of course, the understanding
is if that changes, then he goes to the
Medina verses. Okay?
>> So this is a well understood doctrine,
this sort of evolution. And uh if you
read Arabic, I know you do, um it's it's
always spelled out by Muslim exites and
Islamic scholars in the modern era say
of course uh he really systematized this
idea and um you know showed all the
Quranic verses and also from the hadith
in the S how everything kind of fit into
these uh pattern the the patterns of um
evolution. And so at any rate, that's
the idea. And once he once he went to
Medina and he became stronger and then
we get the violent verses, then he went
on the war path and eventually conquered
Mecca. Okay? And uh and his and most of
Arabia until he died in 632 and then his
successors, the caliphates as we call
them. Then they Abu Bakr during the
so-called wars, wars against the
apostates, he brought them all to heal
and now Islam essentially uh governed uh
Arabia. Okay. So now and this is this
this is the point where it gets
interesting now for me because what I've
I think what I've discussed is it it
really borders on doctrine and it's very
important of course but I think there's
a great lacuna for the people who like
us or the people who you know in the
anti- jihadist movement as it's called
they very much focus on what we just
described but they don't understand how
it was put into practice historically.
Okay. And so it be it unfortunately
becomes an abstract idea. And this is
why apologists
uh who would who would argue against
let's say you or me will say something
like well just because it's in
scriptures doesn't mean Muslims did it.
And then there's this idea that
historically Muslims didn't do this.
They were actually the good guys and the
Christians were the bad guys. So it
becomes uh they use the same same you
know they'll tell you like look at the
old testament or the Jewish scriptures.
Look at all the violence in them. you
know the wars of extermination that
Joshua for example engaged in and just
because it's written in that book
doesn't mean this is exactly what you
have to do today. So they this is one of
the arguments and this is why it was
important for me to show that okay so
let's look at the history let's see did
it did it did it reflect was it a
manifestation of this doctrine or is it
different now of course if you talk to
your average historian western academic
who are essentially indoctrinated and
bred into the very apologetic
pro-Islamic anti-western they will tell
you no of course Islam historically was
a glorious force of advancement and
progress and Lucia
you know the glories of a bassid Baghdad
etc etc so that book that you mentioned
sword and scimitar is actually a product
of 20 years of research and study that
goes back to my college days in uh my
master's thesis which I've completed in
2001 was the battle of yarmmuk which was
the first pivotal pivotal battle and
that actually became chapter one of my
book um but I had continued doing uh
lots of research and I uh got a lot of
my sources when I was working at the
library of congress so that was
definitely advant contagious because a
lot of the sources are very hard to find
in including in Arabic. There were a lot
of sources there. At anyway, so now
let's uh encapsulate what happened once
the jihad uh exploded um on Christendom
essentially. So, okay. So the first uh
corrective most people don't understand
that in the 7th century we're talking
about now which is when Muhammad dies
and the jihad begins bas basically the
fir the first attacks now on infidels
Christians start around 634 636 and the
pivotal battle which I mentioned would
be the battle of Yarmmuk and it's
against the Christians of the north
living in Syria who are the Byzantines
what we call the Byzantines or
essentially the successors.
>> Sorry Raymond I'm just going to
interrupt you for one moment. you you
did use the word jihad a couple times
and I wanted you to just stop for a
moment and and just give us a little bit
of a um a definition of the word jihad
please.
>> Sure. So the word jihad um it comes from
as as you know probably in Arabic
they're all based on triliteral roots
consonants and uh and it's actually a
very analytical language Arabic unlike
other languages which is basically you
have three consonants and then depending
on where the vowels go before in the
middle or whatever you get various words
that are all interrelated.
So for example uh m you know M KT
okay or no MKB MKT you can turn that
into mech means desk mecha uh you know
library kib an author k book okay and
this is important to understand so when
we talk about the word jihad so the word
jihad really comes from the threeletter
roots jhd okay and what they mean
literally is to strive to struggle Okay.
Uh so if I use it in a verb and again
depending on where the the vowels would
go um if I'm engaged in I'm striving I'm
struggling. But then it became its own
word jihad. Okay. And so in its root it
means of course to struggle or to strive
for something some righteous cause. But
in its practice it meant holy war. And
this is why
>> I like to I like to remind people I like
to equate it with mine comp which means
my struggle as well.
>> Yeah. I wrote an article about exactly
that about 18 years ago on NRO comparing
the word mine comp my struggle with my
my jihad. And um so on the one hand it's
important to remember that when an
English per when when you translate an
Arabic word it's fair to translate it
not necessarily into its literal meaning
in this case strive or struggle but into
it you know into the connotation not the
denotation. And so the connotation
amongst Muslims when you said the word
jihad it meant holy war it meant warfare
on the infidel. And so in that sense it
was fair for early orientalists of the
19th century and so forth when they came
across this little foreign word jihad.
It's now it's popular so we can say
jihad. But when they came across it they
translated into holy war because that's
what it really meant. So in this in the
writings of the jurists and the
historians in the period that I'm going
to discuss uh post Muhammad and well
into you know the centuries of conquest
against Europe. Jihad. And I like how
you actually pronounce it in Arabic, but
I'm so caught up. I always pronounce
things like uh in American I say Muslim
instead of Muslim. I say jihad instead
of jihad. Okay. So I need to I need to
be cognizant of that.
>> Um so
>> yeah. So uh basically
now here's the interesting thing. So
that's what it meant historically.
Warfare against the keer, the infidel,
right? and and that's why it's perfectly
legit to translate it into a holy war.
Now, what's interesting is the Muslim
apologists and western apologists will
argue with someone like me and say,
"See, you even admit it. It means
struggle. It doesn't mean holy war. It
could mean anything." The problem with
this interpretation is it actually makes
it worse for Muslims. It makes the issue
actually more more um uh the danger
involved is actually more subtle. So
what what they're saying is no it
doesn't mean holy war it means struggle
strive well okay but we all know that
it's in the context of struggling and
striving on behalf of empowering Islam
according to the vision which is in the
Quran that Islam must govern the entire
world it's definitely in the Sharia
worldview okay so when you say that when
you say it really means strive that
makes it worse and it makes sense of
what's happening today because
historically to struggle to do jihad
meant warfare because you're not going
to get a Christian or a European or
whoever to submit through subtrafuge or
through propaganda or through
indoctrination or through playing the
victim. The only way you were going to
beat them is on the field of battle. So
that's why it meant that. Today however
uh it is in fact a struggle that has man
is is manifesting itself in many
different subtle ways. And so amongst
Muslim jurists today, they will talk
about, and I'm giving you the English
translations, they'll say jihad of the
womb or the baby jihad. They'll talk,
which is basically, I am struggling. I
am doing I'm working on behalf of Islam
by having as many children as I can,
whether I'm a woman or a man
impregnating. Okay? And you see this
obviously happening in Europe. There is
jihad of the pen and jihad of the
tongue. This is propaganda. Okay? Oh, I
am striving on behalf of Islam, but I'm
doing it by whatever deception, through
propaganda, through apologetics, through
lies. There's jihad, okay? Money, the
money jihad. I'm not committed to the
jihad. I'm a rich Saudi, but I spend
millions on the cause. I give it to
terrorist groups, okay? And there's all
kinds. We can get into that. So, the
fact that it actually means to struggle
and strive makes it worse. And it just
shows you how multi-entacled it really
is. Historically, like I said, it's
warfare. And it still is warfare. That
is its primary connotation. That's what
when you read a Islamic in Arabic jur
jeridical text, jihad means war. Okay.
But now that we are now that we're in
this very interesting stage, it has sort
of morphed back to its original meaning
of being struggling in any way possible.
So that's what we're having.
Is that sufficient? Shall I continue
with the historic?
>> No, this is this is great. I think just
to summarize everything you've said till
now, I'm just going to read a quote from
your book where you said
>> Muhammad had only won over some 100
followers after a decade of peaceful
preaching in Mecca, but nearly the whole
of Arabia after a decade of successful
raiding. So I think that just you know
encapsulates both the importance of
hijra and the importance of jihad. So
the successful raiding,
>> the raping and pillaging, that's what
allowed Islam to spread so successfully.
Um so jihad is is in incredibly
important in Islam. It's as you were
just mentioning um
to jihad. So that means to you know to
this struggle or this fight for Allah to
spread Islam generally. That's what it
means. Again, you talk in your book
about how, and this is something I've
learned and every Muslim growing up
anywhere in the world has also learned
that in order to use your life to lose
your life in the endeavor of jihad is is
the best way to spend your life because
then we go ahead after that and start to
talk about all of the rewards that
people get um for losing their life in
the endeavor of jihad, lining up for
battle. battle in the path of Allah,
Muhammad said, is worthier than 60 years
of worship.
And when they engage in this jihad,
their their gift or their reward is of
course the highest levels of heaven and
all of these wonderful things on in
heaven that they can't get on earth. And
one of those things that's,
you know, um, illustrated to them in
such detail is how they're going to get
these,
how they're going to. So, that's the
next question that I wanted to talk to
you about. I wanted to talk to you about
who what are these hoodies? What are
these celestial perpetual virgins that
are going to be gifted to successful
jihadis? And how has that,
you know, corrupted the minds of these
men and how did that contribute to
millions of Western women being taken as
slaves in the Arab world?
>> So before I answer that, because what
you just said actually reminded me of
something very important which will lead
to the the huri question. Um, so I'd
just unpack something very close. uh
very related to that and if I missed the
please please remind me um but the
idea uh which you quoted earlier about
you know the 10 years he had no
followers 100 and then it grew so why is
that and it's because if you really the
to me the genius of Muhammad I often say
this is that he took the tribal mores of
his time 7th century Arabia which was
immensely tribal and he deified them or
he he rearticulated them through a
theological paradigm okay and so what
happened is tribalism as we know
especially 7th century Arabian tribalism
is so extreme it's basically we the
tribe are humans you who are not part of
my tribe are the enemy you are free game
if I come across you and you're not my
tribe I can kill you rape you enslave
you that's absolutely fine
>> okay and so Muhammad sort of took that
but again like I said we articulated in
the theological paradigm and now it was
no longer the tribe was no longer blood
kin it was the believers it was the um
which really does begin in Medina
>> and uh everyone else became outside the
tribe became the enemy. Okay, so this is
another way of looking at why the bad
the infidel is the enemy because he's
outside of the tribe and until he he he
submits and becomes part of it we can
kill him, raid him, rape, you know,
plundered etc. But at the same time, it
because it's infused with a theological
idea, it became even more powerful
because now I can go raid the infidel,
the outsider, and I can take his women
and his children and his blood and his
wealth. Okay? But now if I die doing
that, I go to heaven and I get the same
thing, even more of it, more women, more
pleasure because it's a very hedonistic
paradise. So in many ways uh you know
the what Muhammad did is he just like I
said took this tribalism but turned it
into what I call the win-win strategy
which is now like old old tribalism or
secular tribalism. It's warfare and you
get what you get but you also might die.
But now if you die you still get you
win. You're actually you win more
because you go to heaven and you get the
the the 72, you know, they
translate them as, you know, dark eyed,
blackeyed virgins who are essentially
supernatural
sex women who were created for the
express purpose to gratify Allah's
favorites in perpetuity. Okay? I mean,
it's it's it's insane. And the very
earliest critics of Islam, you know, uh,
John of Damascus who lived in the 7th
century, this is what or theophanes,
this is what they would point out. They
would say, "This is just, you know,
disgusting. This man's entire appeal is
to appeal to the basist instinct of his
followers by allowing them to kill and
plunder and rape and at the same time
feel like you're holy for doing that.
And if you die, you actually go to
heaven." So it was a very strong um I
think uh appeal that this is why this is
why when he was just preaching peace he
got no followers and when he went to Med
Medina and went on the war path they
started to grow exponentially and with
each new conquest which we'll get into
they grew exponentially
um and as far as the you know the
that we discussed the hurries which I
also always find funny because I wonder
if the English word is sort of
etmologically based Huri because we do
have a lot of English words that come
back from Arabic words like assassin
which comes from the hasheen which is an
Islamic uh group. But at any rate so you
know in and it's interesting because
when you read the and I quote them in
the book when you read about Muslims
dying on the field of battle they
supposedly see the the Horries coming
down and welcoming them you know with
with their open arms and it comes out.
Now the funny thing is you know this
isn't just or not it's not funny maybe
sad. This isn't just stuff of history
because until this very day like you
there's quotes of Muslims who are
suicide bombers who talk about how
they're doing this and they're going to
be rewarded by the warm races of the
hurries, okay, who who like I said are
even in the Quran depicted as being very
large bosomed and I mean they're just
basically like sex dolls, okay? Um, so
that's who they are. And in many ways,
of course, this is what has also caused
Muslims to sexually objectify all women
because if that's part of the doctrine,
you know, and I know you were asking me
about the uh the sexual enslavement, but
I suppose I can mention that during the
context of the jihad on Europe. Um, and
if you'd like, I can proceed with that.
>> Yes, please. Let's keep going. Yeah.
>> Okay. So uh we left off sort of you know
um Arabia has been consolidated under
the first khalif Abu Bakr and then um
under the second khalif Omar b
um which is starting around 644 which is
when um I'm sorry 634 when Abu Bakr dies
this is when the real jihad explodes on
the regions adjacent to Arabia now and
they were overwhelmingly Christian and
this is what so many people don't
understand when you talk about 7th
century when you talk about the rise of
Muhammad and and and the subsequent
jihad
uh the what we today are so casually
call the Islamic world was actually the
heart of the Christian world. Okay. So
greater Syria as it was known which
today encompasses Jordan, Lebanon,
Israel, the Palestinian regions um and
all the way up north it was greater
greater Syria. That was one of the if
not the oldest Christian region. Okay.
So was Egypt. So was all the way uh you
know you go to Morocco or Megared and
not the point is they weren't just
Christian. They were literally more
Christian than the West. Okay. Uh you
know think of it as this way. There were
five C's as they call the major major
Christian centers. Only one was in the
west Rome. Okay. The other four were in
the east and this would be Alexandria.
It would be Antioch. It would be
Jerusalem and later Constantinople. And
those four all got conquered and
swallowed up by Islam. And the only one
that was left was actually Rome. And I
always marvel at how people don't
understand that you know during this
time this was a Christian heavily
heavily Christian region. The reason
Constantine moved the capital of Rome
from Rome to Nova Rome, New Rome or
Constantinople. It's named after him
which is far in the east. It's actually
today in Turkey. Uh is because that's
where Christendom was. That's where the
more sophisticated, the more learned,
the richer part of the Christian world
was. And in one century during these
jihads that I'm discussing, they were
all conquered. Okay? So all of greater
Syria, all of Egypt, all of North
Africa. And and the reason I say one
century is Muhammad dies in 632. 732 now
you have the battle of uh Tours or
Poatier which is right in the middle of
France. Okay? So that is how much
territory the Muslims conquered all of
which was Christian until they got to
the middle of uh of France. They also
incidentally of course conquered Persia
which was Zorastrian at the time. And
they also went further east and
conquered uh India and and and further
and and the blood baths there are
especially horrific especially uh the
Indians because they were seen as pagans
uh you know so their blood is
immediately halal. They can kill you
outright. Um but so and this is why it's
uh you know you I know you're you're
half Egyptian half um Palestinian. Your
ancestors far far back are probably a
cop Coptic and Egyptian and a Christian
Palestinian. Uh you know the word cop
all it means is Egyptian. U you know
it's we our word Egyptian comes from the
Greek agyptos. Egypttos and the Arabs
came in and called all those people who
were Christians gipped. They cut off the
the beginning and the end. So it's not a
giptos, it's just gipped. And then it
became kipp and now it's in English it's
cop and it just essentially meant an
Egyptian who of course was a Christian
at the time. Uh so unfortunately none of
this is being taught uh in in you know
academia. I've looked at school books,
textbooks people send me, parents send
me you know what their kids learn and
you get one very hygienic sentence about
how through trade Islam spread.
Okay. But if you look at these this
century that I'm talking about and it's
in my book Sword and Scimitar I I think
three chapters are just based on that
first century. It's just constant
warfare, destruction of churches,
slaughter of Christians and other
people. The Berbers especially in North
Africa had it horrifically mass slavery,
tens of thousands of people. And then
they went into Europe uh in Spain in the
year 7-Eleven and essentially it fell
and was conquered except for a small
quadrant in the northwest where the
reconista uh actually started. We can
get into that. And then like I said a
few years later they were they had
penetrated France and they were finally
stopped there. Okay. But it didn't end
there. And then you know there's there
was a sort of transitional period. Now
you have the rise of the Turks and the
Arabs begin to Wayne and then the Turks
start pouring in and they become the new
standard bearers of the jihad and it
gets launched again and now they're in
the Balkans now. uh uh and this is this
is again this is where the worst time is
when the Turks really came it got really
bad and under actually even before that
the the one that I want to I like to
cite just to give you an idea of both
how Christian the Middle East was and
both the persecution that Christians
experienced in the year 109 the the the
Fatimid Egypt a lot of people don't know
was actually governed for a couple of
century by Shia uh that's what the
Fatimids were but the Fatimid Khalif
Hakimah
actually destroyed according to El Maki
and an Arabic Muslim historian 30,000
churches in both Egypt and greater
Syria. So again this underscores just
how profoundly Christian that region was
and how profound the persecution was in
one year. Um so and they als he also
ordered the destruction of the holy
sephiler. Okay, that which is the most
important uh church in Jerusalem for
Christians because it's believed to be
built on the site of Christ's uh
crucifixion and resurrection that was
completely raised to the ground. And
it's that sort of thing and pilgrims who
were coming from Europe were being
attacked and killed and very horrific
stuff. There's a story in in a
contemporary story of a German nun who
because she was so attractive the Turks
took her and gang raped her until she
died. Okay. And then the chronicler and
it's in sort and symmetry if you want
the source and the chronicler says and
they did this often. Okay. And that is
the buildup for the first crusade which
otherwise we are often presented with in
a vacuum. Okay. I I've quoted him
before. We have uh his historians and
academics like John Espazito of
Georgetown UN University where I went
over two decades ago who literally says
before the first crusade everything for
centuries was peace and love between
Christians and Muslims. Okay. So what I
just told you, the conquest, the
destruction of churches, the slavery,
that didn't happen until these evil
crazy crusaders decided to ruin it all
and go and and just, you know, and until
then, Muslims are really upset and have
grievances and they they they don't m
they mistrust Westerners because of
that. That's complete garbage, of
course. Uh because like I said right up
in in the years aside from what I've
been telling you now in the years before
the first crusade in the 1050s 60s7s
Asia Minor what we call now today Turkey
or Anatolia which was again one of the
most ancient Greek regions I'm sorry
ancient Christian regions and it was
mostly Greeks and Armenians and Syriaks
living there according to the
contemporary sources tens of thousands
of them were being butchered and
massacred. Okay. And hundreds of
thousands were being hauled off into
slavery by the Turks, the Seljic Turks.
And the churches in Ani, which was the
capital of Armenia and was known as, you
know, the city of a thousand1 churches.
Every single church was desecrated and
burned to the ground. Okay, these are
the events that Pope Urban II at the
council of Claremont in 1095. This is
the beginning of the first crusade. That
is what he was talking about and and we
have it. It survives in many texts.
Okay? He was talking about what Muslims
were doing to Christians and to
churches. And that's the first crusade.
Okay. But like I said, today it's just
always presented in a vacuum as if
everything was fine until these evil
westerners decided to go and ruin
everything. Um, and that of course is
done by design and intention to again
make the victim look like the aggressor,
Christians, and to exonerate the
aggressors, uh, Muslims. Well, that's
that's how it's presented in the West,
but that's not how it's presented in the
Muslim world because we're all raised on
these we know about all these battles
and all these conquests and we're raised
to feel pride over them. So, you know,
it it's two completely different.
>> Yep. Exactly. Um these are our bedtime
stories, right? These these are this is
>> this is what you're everybody's very
aware. So for them to over here in the
west to pretend that Arabs were just
busy, you know, building sand castles
and frolicking and joy before um the
crusades is absolutely garbage and
untrue. Um
another point that I wanted to mention
um was about
so the that we mentioned before they as
you described their eyes you know or we
get told what their eyes look like their
bosoms look like and we're also told
about their skin and it talks about how
their skin is so white so that you can
see the veins
um beneath the skin and and there was a
constant obsession with lighter skin,
whiter skin And all of these things that
you described, including in in there are
white women, western women or Christian
women being taken as sex slaves in what
we now refer to, you know, gloss over it
as a euphemism and just call it like
herums. But that's what those herums
were filled with. They were they were
filled with women who were basically
kidnapped, taken as hostages and and
enslaved. Is did the crusades were the
crusades a reaction to that as well?
>> Well, yeah. So, what you bring up a very
important point and you know we earlier
we were talking about the motivations of
the jihad, okay, the plunder, etc. The
desire for fairs skinned women goes all
the way back actually to Muhammad and
few people know this. So there's a uh in
one of the hadith he basically there's
what's called the tabuk campaign one of
the last campaigns that he went on which
was against the Byzantines. Okay. So,
Greeks, fair skinned people and anyway
it never manifested. But before it
there's a hadith where he's trying to
cajul one a man to come and join the you
know the expedition and he tells them
don't you want the women of yellow
benar okay which uh historians and
linguists have translated as meaning
either blondhaired people or pale
skinned people okay and the man says
something oh oh prophet of Allah you
know I have such a weak desire for that
but I I don't know if I want to commit
or or something to that effect okay It
goes all the way back to Muhammad. He
used that as an enticement or as a lure
that you can conquer and get these fairs
skinned blonde women. Okay? And it comes
out repeatedly in the sources actually
in the book sword in scimitar I go to
some length quoting it. So when they
went into Spain for example which was
then the Visigoththic Spain these were
essentially Germanic people. Um Tarb
tar benzed who actually is the one you
know he's the hero of the conquest of
Spain. He also cajolled his men by
likening them saying, "Oh, the women
there look like the hurries and they're
waiting for you. They're all just
waiting for you." Okay. Also, the entire
slave trade. Okay. A lot of people don't
know the Vikings, you know, this is a
quote with what was happening. The
Viking main, you know, the main years of
the Viking attacks on Western Europe,
uh, you know, around 800 to a thousand
generally or late 700s. Um and this
coincides of course with the Abbassad um
caliphate and a lot of the raids that
the Vikings did on you know England and
in Ireland and Northern France and
wherever was to get slaves, white
slaves, primarily slave women to sell to
the Abbassad Muslim caliphate because
there was a huge demand for that. Okay,
this is one of those things that people
don't re seem to realize. Okay, so that
that kind of thing goes on and on
repeatedly. It comes out uh in you know
it comes out in the is early Islamic
sources and it comes out when you read
the actual conquest who was being
enslaved and why and how they boast
about you know they got fair skinned
people. They went in the 16th century as
far to Iceland. Okay, North African
Muslims would travel. They attacked
Iceland. They attacked Denmark. They had
a small island off the coast of England
and it was all dedicated to raiding and
taking white slaves and selling them in
North Africa on the slave markets. Okay,
so this was definitely a real thing.
Now, what I also find interesting is in
these early Islamic sources, believe it
or not, they go out of their way very
lurid and pornographic descriptions of
white women presenting them as
inherently promiscuous. Okay. So, on the
one hand, they present them as very
beautiful and I'm thinking I quote I
actually just made a video about a week
ago about this topic on my YouTube
channel if anyone wants to see it. But
it because I have the quote there, you
can read it. But, uh, one academic says,
you know, that that they go out of their
way to describe these women as
beautiful. But then she admits that but
then their characterization of their
morals are anything but beautiful.
They're very ugly. They present them
essentially as harlots who want to do
nothing. Even the nuns, you know,
western Christian nuns were all
basically at heart. And it's very
very pornographic. And I also cite and
quote one of the um an eyewitness of uh
part of Saladins Salahedin's entourage
during the conquest of Jerusalem. And he
has this long quote where he just bows.
He's so it's so sat masochistic. It's
about how all these Frankish white women
who are being enslaved because the
Muslims won are going to be penetrated.
They're going to be crying. Men are
going to enjoy them. really really again
if you see the video I have the whole
and it's in sword and scimitar if you
want the long graphic um uh excerpt but
what I really find interesting and the
reason I made that video is the
parallels is the continuity between then
and today because the reason I did it is
today in Europe especially in England
but all throughout in Germany um there's
so many instances of Muslims not only
praying on fair-skinned women sexually
but they maintain that same motif which
is you women are good at it. You women
are made for this. You are And
it goes all the way back, as I'm telling
you, to early early Islam, including
Muhammad. You know, this unwavering
continuity. This is where it comes from.
And we have anecdotes of this all
through from Australia and Germany where
Muslim men attack women and say that's
what you're for, etc., etc. So, this the
female thing is a very real thing. It
goes all the way back. It's it's in the
it's in the scriptures themselves. It
manifested manifested itself all
throughout history and it's still
happening till this very day. Uh the
difference of course being westerners
are inviting it and welcoming it whereas
at least their ancestors would fight
against it.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Yes. Absolutely
agree with you. Thank you for showing us
that common thread. Um, which is, you
know, a very important one, especially
post October 7th. Um, and knowing about
all of the Pakistani rape gangs all over
England, for example, like there there
are a lot of like as you mentioned, um,
we can definitely see those the the
clear continuity.
Let's continue down that path a little
bit more and find some more threads that
we can you know show how from the
beginnings of Islam to today the same
patterns keep repeating themselves we to
see the continuity. So if we go back to
Hijra for example
um or whatever it is I mean you have
been studying
you know you refer to primary sources in
Arabic Greek and other languages to
conduct your research you've been
studying these battles between Islam and
the West for so long. So what do you see
as um how these battles inform your
understanding of what we're facing
today? So, what are some glaring
similarities that you find happening
today where you're like, "Oh my gosh,
history truly does repeat itself."
>> Can you hold that thought? And I think
to to help enrich your question, I'll
just finish the history thing because
I'm almost done. I think I left off
course I left off with the Crusades or
something. No, no, it'll take five
minutes because it'll help
>> it'll help clarify because it's closer
to our time. So, I think I was talking
about the first crusade. Now forget
about the crusades and the rise of the
Ottomans. Now it's a new and this is an
important point that I think uh I make
in the book and I think people need to
understand which is um it the in the
historically so as we mentioned first
you have the Arabs right and there are
the Muslims and then you get the Turks
and then you get you know the Mongols
people forget about the Mongols but a
significant portion of them became
Muslims okay there are the Stan nations
today you know Kazakhstan Turk manistan
and those regions who are which are
Muslim um what's interesting is you know
these are all different peoples from
different, you know, epochs of time,
different eras, different centuries.
They spoke different languages, had
their own cultures, um, and so forth.
And yet you find the same unwavering
mentality and opus, uh, um, um, modus
oper operende of operation, okay, which
is based on Islam and based on the jihad
and based on the Quran. So my point is
you have these various iterations of
different peoples and yet they all acted
the same way, okay? And when you read
modern histories, this doesn't come out.
What they do is they'll talk about Arab
conquests. They won't mention Islam.
They'll talk about the Turk conquests
and then they'll talk about the Mongols
and you won't understand that there's a
common thread to all three which is
Islam. Um and they because they'll
sidestep the religious issue and they'll
just make it they always focus on it
from a national prism. Okay? So the
Turks are a people, the Mongols are a
people, Arabs, etc. And I just have
always found it fascinating that despite
that fact um they all acted in the same
exact way. They all quoted the same
Islamic scriptures and rationale for
jihad and conquest. Um, so I think that
that's I I find that very fascinating.
So now we're talking real quickly about
the Turks and the Ottomans. And now
these guys go into the Balkans. They
conquer Constantinople finally in 1453.
And it's in my book actually chapter uh
I think six or seven. The the the the
atrocities committed just boggle the
mind. Okay. of what happened in
Constantinople on May 29th, 1453. And
one of the reasons that we we know all
this is actually because it's not so far
1453 is a lot closer than 7332.
Okay? But I believe they were all always
as horrific and as sadistic as uh comes
out in 1453. But after that, think about
it again under this jihadi imperative,
they conquered the Balkans, Greece, uh
you know, all those regions. Albania
became Islamized. And you know it's
today I think it's uh half Muslim for
example as well as these other Serbian
regions and they went all the way uh
Hungary was conquered for about 150
years. Vienna was attacked twice you
know the Holy Roman Empire capital at
the time in 1529 and again in 1683. Now
look at that 1683. This is a thousand
years now after uh the first attack on
Christian civilization. And at that time
you had something like 200,000 jihadis
encircle uh Vienna. Okay. And and
there's a reason why Eastern European
countries are are a little more wary of
Islam as opposed to Western European
countries. And it's because this history
is not so far away from them. It's a
recent memory and they know this. And
then they see again they see the
continuity when Muslims come into
Western Europe and they behave in the
same sort of way. So one understands why
that is the case. Um but you know so
this continues until even America. So,
you know, Americans don't realize that
their first this nation's America's
first nation, I'm sorry, America's first
war as a nation once it became a nation
after the revolutionary or war of
dependence of independence was against
Muslims who were thinking and acting the
same exact way, the Barbrey Wars as we
call them. And again, when you hear
about Barbary Wars, the way it's
presented, it's just a bunch of pirates
in North Africa and they don't really
talk about the religion. But we know
that Thomas Jefferson and John Adams. So
what was happening before that is these
pirates, Barbary pirates, Muslims were
attacking and invading American vessels
after they gained independence because
they were no longer being protected by
Britain. And they were enslaving their
crews and torturing them and killing
them. And finally, long story short,
Thomas Jefferson John Adams met one of
their ambassadors and he said, "What?
You know, we've done nothing wrong to
you. We'd like we can be friends. We can
trade. Why are you attacking us?" And
the ambassador quoted essentially a
paraphrase of Quran 95 which I told you
is a the sword verse and he said because
according to our book and our prophet
all of those who reject our authority
meaning who are not Muslim are enemies
and it's our right to attack kill
plunder and enslave them and if we die
we go to heaven okay and that and
eventually that led to the first war
that America had as a nation. Okay and
how many people know that? So now we're
in the year 1800. Okay, we started in
the 600s. Now we're 12 centuries into it
and it's the same jihadist imperative uh
and motivation being quoted verbatim.
Okay. And yet we're told, "No, this is
all wrong." Okay? So now let's fast
forward to the modern era. ISIS, you
know, the Islamic State and the other
radical organizations, they come on the
scene and they start doing what they're
doing and everyone tells us, "Oh,
they've hijacked Islam. This is not
Islam. Islam does not do that." that
actually they have modeled themselves
perfectly in in lock step with the
caliphates that I'm talking about
because they were all governed and and
functioning under Islamic law, Sharia
and the jihadist worldview and this is
how you treat the infidel. They are
actually the most accurate
representatives of historical Islam when
Islam is strong. Okay. And we've been
told no, they're not. And in many ways
that's that is the grand conclusion of
my book Sword and Scimitar. It shows you
the history and then we get to, you
know, this the these crazy terrorists
who have nothing to do with Islam and
you find that they are the they're the
perfect copy of what the history has
actually shown. Okay. So, I think I'll
I'll stop the historical thing there and
we can continue on what other questions
you had. I think what are the what are
the parallels today?
>> Yeah,
>> I think so I'll answer that. And you
know the parallels today what's now
here's the the parallels are this and I
call it I call it Islamic continuity
versus western confusion. Okay, Muslims
are still acting on the same playbook.
Okay, but by and large Islam is much
weaker than the West. Much weaker than
most of the world. This is the irony.
Okay, Islam inherently is not uh econ is
not economically or militarily or
technologically anywhere near advanced
as most of the rest of the world
especially the west. So the strategies
the struggling the driving the jihad has
taken on different forms. All right. And
on the same time, at the same time,
what's happening is because the West is
so amnesic and and and doesn't know any
of this and goes out of its way to
present Muslims as victims. If anything,
it was evil Christians, evil Europeans
who actually were attacking and hurting
Muslims, you know. So, they are so naive
that they are, you know, the Muslim the
Muslim jihad or jihad or struggle that I
mentioned earlier, they are susceptible
to it. So they bring them into Europe by
the millions and uh the the demographic
jihad goes on the baby jihad. Look at
all these in all these countries in
Western Europe or especially the major
capitals the number one name of newborn
baby boys is Muhammad you know isn't
that just amazing thinking about that
and uh you know so that's just one one
example this sort of and it's it's the
hijra they're migrating they're not
assimilating they're creating their own
enclaves and what is the what does the
western authorities do they're cowtowing
to them and giving them more of what
they want and when the native
populations of Europe complain saying
they shut them down in the UK or in
Brin. I think if you say what I'm
saying, you will go to jail. Okay?
Doesn't matter if it's true. So that's
the strange uh uh you know state of
affairs. On the one hand, Muslims, like
I say, they're just they're behaving the
way Islam has always behaved. There's no
surprise here. It's what the West is
doing. Okay? And what the West is
allowing. I liken it to the idea, you
know,
if I put a, you know, if you put a lion,
if you if I take a lion, he's in an
enclosure and I throw in a bunch of
zebras and then the lion kills the
zebras, who's at fault? Is it the lion
or me?
>> You know, and uh so I think to a large
extent, a lot of the people, especially
in Europe, need to understand the real
problem is not the Muslims, it's the
people who are bringing them in and
empowering them and allowing this to
happen. Because the Muslims are not
coming waving swords like they did
before and forcing their entry. They are
being brought in by the people who
govern you and who are supposedly
representing you. And it's high time
they open their eyes and understand that
this is not this isn't just naive
politicians or politically correct
politicians. This is there's an agenda
obviously here. Um and the longer they
wait the worse it's going to be or
harder it's going to be to ameliorate
it.
>> Yeah. And exactly what you described to
us at the very beginning here with you
know from Mecca to Medina and how every
you know Muhammad was preaching very
gently very you know kumbaya everything
was fine and dandy let's all be friends
and brotherhood until he got to a
certain amount of power. So until his
number grew to a certain amount and
that's that's very critical because
that's when things switch. That's when
he changed and that's really important
for us to recognize that we can see that
happening already all across Europe and
the west where and obviously in India
and all over the world where you can see
that it there's a certain amount of this
appeasement goes on for a while until it
gets to a certain demographic number
whereas you talked about all the
different ways of jihad you know it they
don't have to come in wielding swords
they can come in wielding you know
pregnant four pregnant wives
you know what I mean? That there's other
ways to change the demographics and to
make it more um you know to give Muslims
more of control over the politics really
um as as a voting power. So yeah, I
think that all of those points you
described are very clear. Thank you so
much Raymond for everything. you have
really really succinctly and very
poignantly clarified everything um over
the 1400 years. It was really amazing.
Thank you so much.
>> I'm going to move now.
>> Thank you. I'm going to move into the
the questions from our audience.
The first one, there's actually two
different questions, but I'm going to
combine them into one. One person was
asking about the how Muhammad died and
another person was asking about did he
um
did he name a successor when he died? So
those are two very big questions
especially the second one. So what can
you tell us about that? I the Islamic
narrative that he died is I think he
just like he got sick of some stomach
flu and died but then there's conspiracy
theories that say he was poisoned and I
believe some say his young wife Asia u
uh you know but this might be part of
the Shia Sunni conflict uh might be an
accusation so I don't know but I don't
think we really know um but you know in
the standard Islamic narrative is just
he just I mean because in that day and
age if he's born in 516 he might he
would have been 62 So after a lifetime
of warfare, it's not uncommon to die in
the 7th century at that age. Um but I
think the sources are not clear. It's
just essentially ascribed to just some
sickness that he got. Um and what was
I'm sorry the second question.
>> Did he name a successor?
>> Um
>> I believe
well this is the whole Sunni Shia
problem.
>> Okay. It depends on who you ask, right?
Uh the Sunnis would say yes that he he
he allotted it to Abu Bakr who was you
know his father-in-law and friend the
father of Aisha who I just said some
said poisoned him. Uh interesting. So he
became the actual leader. But of course
to the Shia they said no it has to be a
descendant of Muhammad. Uh which at the
time would have been you know a child of
Fatima his daughter married to his
cousin Ali. Okay. And so again hence the
Shia Sunni conflict. So these are the
kind of questions it depends on who
you're going to ask and you know but
most people even I think she is would
agree that this it was okay to have
successors at the time uh including Abu
Bakr it's f you know the split becomes
later after the you know U men and then
then this is when the big you know the
battle in 680 that happens and then this
and the Shia are killed and Ali and and
so forth. So it you know it depends on
it depends on the version but it's a
very contentuous question amongst Sunnis
and Shia.
>> Mhm.
Okay great. Um and the next question is
is there a proper trustworthy
translation of the Quran into English.
>> That's a good question and I'll tell you
this the newer they are the worse they
are. Okay. And um I I I the way the
things they do, the liberties they take
to soften it, you know. So for example
uh you know I think I quoted 929 Quran
929 which says fight the people of the
book Christians and Jews until they
until they become Muslim or pay tribute
feeling themselves humbled. Now they'll
say something like uh fight the people
of the book who fight you first. Okay,
that's not in Arabic. Sorry. No Muslim
has ever believed that. So, actually the
one that I like which is decent and it's
actually online um I can pull it up.
Yeah, I think it's just quran.com quur
an international version and at least
they're they're honest enough to when
they put the soft stuff they put it in
brackets
>> implying so they're saying that's the
implication but it's not in the Arabic.
The reality is it's not even the
implication. Okay, it's not in the
Arabic and it's not in the implication.
So this is a real problem and if
anything it's sad to say but the old
orientalist translations would be more
accurate even though they're very now
they would be laughed off as oh you know
these were these guys had a you know
chip on they had an an axe to grind
against Islams is the idea thanks to
Edward say but actually they would be
closer than the stuff I had an Oxford it
was sent to me to review an I think
Oxford Quran and it was just like
>> what am I reading the Bible New
Testament
Right. So,
>> yeah, totally totally whitewashed.
There's more brackets than there are
>> actual words. Right.
>> Yeah.
All right. So, next question. As a
scholar of religion, what are some of
the common apologetics you get from
people trying to explain away the
connections between Islam and the issues
that it faces with modernity?
I'm not fully following the question
like what what do how do Muslims
apologize for their behavior?
>> Yeah. So what are I mean I think you've
spoken quite a bit about this actually.
So what are the common apologetics you
get from Westerners who try to explain
to you that this connection between
Islam and its
>> issues with living in democratic nations
like no it's all in your head kind of
thing like excuses that they use. One of
the strongest I guess is they'll you
know and this is again why I wrote sword
and scimitar is because up until then
people always people on our camp would
argue and say look at the Quran it's
violent it's intolerant etc that was the
main weapon okay it wasn't the
historical argument and the response to
that was basically well look at the
Bible look at the old testament you know
and just because it says violence
doesn't mean people are going to follow
violence and there's different
interpretations and they would talk
about you know the peaceful verses from
Mecca and say, "Well, even if the Medina
one says that, they're still the Meccan
one. They don't know about abrogation.
And if they do, they ignore it." So, and
and and you know, if you're a
superficial observer, you these are
these are compelling arguments again
because like I said, um you know, the
new the Old Testament is is probably
more violent than the Quran if we want
to be honest. You know, the warfare that
goes on, but we already know Christians
who believe in the in the Old Testament
and Jews are not necessarily quoting it
and going to war anymore. And so if you
have that in the back of your mind and
then a Muslim says, "Well, the Quran's
the same thing." And a lot of them,
they'll even make the argument say, "It
was temporary. These were this applied
to the wars back then." But I've
actually done a whole study about two
decades ago to show how the language is
different because it's open-ended, you
know. Whereas when you read the vi the
wars of conquest Joshua's time, it's
very temporal. It names the enemies.
There are people who don't exist,
Jebusites, etc. anymore. And it's, you
know, it's it's a located fixated time.
You're waring with them. It's not an
open-ended command. But the Quran, it
doesn't mention, you know, fighting
Roman Byzantines. It doesn't say
fighting Persians. It says you're
fighting the Kufur, the infidels who are
still us and who are still alive. Okay?
So, there's a that's a subtle but I
think important distinction. But I think
that that's been the main one, which is
basically just because a book says
something doesn't mean it's adherence.
You know, they'll say, "Well, the Old
Testament says shellfish. You're not
supposed to eat it. Everyone eats it
now." So, and that's so that's why I
wanted to write sword and scimitar
because this history was hidden and I
wanted to show that okay well let's see
how Muslims have behaved and lo and
behold when it comes to the doctrine of
jihad it manifested it itself over and
over and over century after century
until it literally I don't think I said
this but if you look at the map of what
was once the Christian world it
swallowed up almost three quarters okay
how many people know that that the 3/4
of the original Christian territory was
permanently conquered and Islam ized uh
by Muslims and this is like I said the
Middle East which we just casually say
oh the Muslim world that was the heart
of Christendom uh Egypt and all North
Africans Syria as well as Asia Minor
Turkey okay all of that so I think
that's why to me the historical argument
is a little more ironclad because what
how can you respond to that you know the
facts are there they said it they
conquered they quoted the Quran and the
hadith they called it a jihad it was
warfare, there was slavery, they were
praying on the white women, etc.,
destroying churches. So, it's, I think,
a lot harder to get beyond that, whereas
it's easy to do the scriptural, oh,
okay, just because some musty old book
says that doesn't mean every Muslim is
living by it.
>> So, Raymond, these next questions are
not asking you historical questions.
They're asking you to just give your own
insights and your own opinions on
things. Um, so one question is, is there
any hope that some Muslim countries will
move away from these violent tendencies?
Maybe the more secular Central Asian
republics s such as Azerbaijan and
Albania. Do you see any of these
countries moving away from this anytime
soon?
>> I I would say certainly some countries
are worse than others. Okay. Um, I would
rather be living amongst Albanian
Muslims and living around Saudi Muslims.
Okay, there's no denying that. Um, but I
I think the real question is, can you be
a Muslim and be and do away with what
we're talking about
>> because of course there's nominal
Muslims who don't do this, who don't
believe this, who don't know about it,
just like there's nominal Christians and
Jews who don't know anything about their
religion. So, but is that really a
reflection of the religion? And I think
that's the question where, you know,
it's one thing to be, okay, I'm a I'm a
casual Muslim, you know, and I don't
know much about this and I live like a
secular person. Okay. And it's another
thing to say, I'm a I'm an observant
Muslim, but I've rejected this. I think
that's a lot harder to do because it's
just there. It's part of your religion.
I don't know how how you know it's
actually it's more sincere and honest
for you to apostasize and just leave the
religion than to play this little game.
Yeah. You know what I mean? And uh so
this is why yeah you can apostasize, you
can be secular and not even know much
about your religion, but if you're but
but the idea that no, I'm a pious Muslim
and I read the Quran and I pray but I
don't believe these things. I find that
rather suspect.
>> Okay, next question. Can Raymond address
how Islamists infiltrate social justice
movements and lie in order to gain
support from leftists? The lying from
what I understand is allowed within the
faith if it's done in the name of the
struggle. Can he explain the concept of
tea?
>> Tea. I'm the guy who actually wrote the
book on tea because I've been writing
about it for one of my oldest articles
which was published by James of James
Analyst and the Middle East Quarterly
almost 18 years ago was all about tea
and tea is uh which it's it might be too
complicated to get into this but the
long and short of it is yes it allows
lying um and it's in its original
manifestation it was based on you're
afraid you're going to get killed by the
infidel so you're going to lie to him
but it's really morphed and there's all
other doctrines which like I think the
question was implying basically you can
lie just empower Islam as long as it's
that you know the end that the end
justifies the means and if the end is
I'm going to empower Islam over the
world of the kafir okay then it's legit
you know Muhammad just because um you
know because a uh a poet a Jewish poet
uh or Ashra bin Kab I believe and this
is again during the Medina times you
know he didn't believe that Muhammad was
a prophet and he mocked him and he made
poetry mocking him. And so one day came
and Muhammad threw his hands up and
said, "Who will rid me of this man?" And
a young Muslim follower came and said,
"I'll do it, but I need to lie to him."
And Muhammad said, "Do it." And the
young man went and basically pretended
that he apostasized. He's no longer with
Muhammad. He hates Muhammad. He agrees
with Cab. And until Kab dropped, the
Jewish poet dropped his guard and took
him as a friend. And before you know it,
he appeared with another Muslim saying
he's also an apostate. when he and then
they just beheaded him and took his head
and threw it to Muhammad and everyone
screamed alahbar. Okay. So, so there was
an exa a perfect example of deception
just to avenge the prophet on someone
who mocked him. Okay. So the uh the
lying especially if you can rationalize
it in your mind you as a Muslim that
it's somehow benefiting Islam or even if
it's benefiting you as a Muslim over a
non-Muslim that's the same thing. Okay.
then it's legit and uh you know it's
there there's all kinds of other
doctrines we can talk about that do
that. Um I don't know if that was the
the whole question. Yeah. Okay.
>> Yeah. No, that was great. Um so now
somebody's asking about the concept of
the Jaha, the age of ignorance,
preIslamic ignorance. Um so amongst the
more tribal Arabs you had civilizations
like the Nabotans who treated
um slaves and women much better than
Muslims did and women were empowered
like Khadijah for example
and so didn't Islam really devolve even
the Arabs themselves did you find that
looking through history that Islam
actually devolved them in these social
issues.
>> Yeah. And it goes back to the idea that
again remember Muhammad, how is he going
to grandise and empower himself? He
needs manpower. So how is he going to
cajul and entice and win over men? He's
going to give them whatever they want,
which would of course mean female
concubine, slavery, and a degradation of
women, um plundering, killing, etc. It
was all justified. Like I said, uh you
know the Quran talks about you know you
can have four wives but and as many as
your right manum you know whatever your
right hand possesses which means
limitless slave women. Okay. So I think
because you know Muhammad's whole again
modus operenda is to empower himself
which in the seventh century meant I
need followers with swords as many as I
can get men of course. So, you know,
everything was done the the message
given to them was always, you know, the
message that would satisfy and gratify
the most primordial urges of men, which
uh just so happened not to coincide with
women's uh welfare.
>> Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
So going back to your um those common
threads that you were showing us, a lot
of people in the chat now are asking
about about more com like more
contemporary things that are happening
right now, especially in American
politics. So looking at Mandani in New
York for example
um are you seeing that his actions or um
what are you seeing for the way he's
acting and the way he's succeeding
um are you finding that he's also using
these typical playbooks that you've been
describing to us?
>> Well, first I'll I'll tell you, you
know, I admit a little ignorance. I
haven't been following him too much, but
I think I can associate it with a
previous question, which is how are how
are the Muslims sort of appropriating
and making use of the useful idiots on
the woke left? And I think that's what
he was he's basically doing. You know,
all his talking points are uh something
that, you know, works with the woke
left. And when it comes from, you know,
a brown Muslim the way, you know,
Americans see it, then oh well, he's a
victim anyway, too. And he's someone who
knows what he's talking about. and uh
you know we can support him but you know
this idea of actually you know garnering
sympathy from the left it actually goes
back into al-Qaeda um in 2005 the book
was published in 2007 my first book the
al-Qaeda reader and I showed how the you
know al-Qaeda leadership um Osama bin
Laden and Aman Zwahi their Arabic
writings towards Muslims was like ISIS
okay oh these are infidels we hate them
on principle etc writings and
communicates all to the west which BBC
and CNN love to quote were all played on
leftist themes. Okay, you are the
aggressor, you're unjust, capitalism is
bad, uh you know, you're you're you're
you're
exploiting us. Uh it was all you're
racist, you're attacking us because
we're brown. That's actually all the
stuff that al-Qaeda would say. Uh and
you know, if people wanted to believe it
was one thing, but then that was the
whole point. I found their writings in
Arabic to fellow Muslims and it was the
opposite. It literally said it doesn't
matter what they do if they're good or
bad towards us. They're the enemies.
They're the caffer. So, back to that
mentality. Um, so I think the the man
you just mentioned in New York is doing
the same exact thing probably in a more
uh you know, suave way from the little
I've seen about him. And, you know,
they're just eating it up because uh
they know how to they know, believe it
or not, Osama bin Laden at one point was
complaining about how America wouldn't
sign the Kyoto protocol for the
environment. Okay. So, if you want to
talk about leftist talking points, they
know how to they know Aan Zawahi once
did a whole message directed at, you
know, the American African-Americans
telling them white people will always
hate you. You know, the only religion
for you is of freedom and equality is
Islam. Yeah. So, they definitely
understand that and they do, you know,
press on those particular buttons.
Mhm.
So, I'm going to ask you one more
question here that I actually just
thought of when you were speaking now,
which you talked when you were talking
about the slave trade and and women and
stuff. um we didn't talk about the the
Arab slave trade in general and how it
obviously predates the European slave
trade and it um continued much further
after um the West stopped enslaving
people. So can you talk to us a little
bit about that history because I think
that's very
not well known at all. In fact, um,
Malcolm X went to Saudi Arabia as a
Muslim while Saudi Arabia was still
buying and selling black human beings as
slaves. He went there to talk about how
his roots are in Islam and how the white
man is the devil. And he's saying this
in a country that's currently engaged in
slavery. So I think there's a real
distortion of you know historical
revisionism. So can you talk to us a bit
about the Arab slave trade?
>> Sure. So the Arab slave trade was a real
thing and it was a very major thing and
it went on uh it went on until the west
forced them to stop. Okay. Yeah.
>> And it wasn't just Arabs. It was of
course Muslims in general but us the
periods we're looking at of course was
during the Arab hegemony but also the
Turks later on and the Mongols actually.
So for example, the Mongols and the
problem is the numbers of how many are
kind of hard to come across simply
because Westerners went out of their way
to record numbers. Muslims didn't. It
wasn't something that you know and even
if they did, they're not going to go
around and show it right now. But we do
come across numbers here and there. And
uh in Sword and Scitar, I actually have
a chapter where I talk about the Slavs,
which is where we get the word slaves
because they were being enslaved so much
by the Muslims. and also the the
Mongols, the Tatars who were Muslim at
the time, especially the Russians. So
you had the Crimean Kate which had I I
quote a number I think something like 4
million Russians and Slavs were enslaved
through it. The Ottomans um you know we
come across various uh uh raids and I
have them in the book you know they they
attacked Hungary and came back with
100,000 slaves or something like that.
They attacked Rome and came back with 40
Romania, 40,000 slaves. Okay, you get
that number. I do know for a fact that
uh according to an American uh historian
who wrote a whole book about this, it's
called I think you know white, you know,
Muslim masters, white slaves. Um and he
says that in the 16th century alone,
there were 1.2 million white slaves just
in North Africa. When I was talking
about remember they went to Iceland and
Denmark to to get white slaves, 1.2
million
Okay. And uh so this goes on now and
then the subsaharan you know the African
slave trade that was also a major thing
but a very interesting point is uh and I
don't know the exact details but I've
read this which is you know in America
you had black slaves but you know not
only did there did they continue to live
on we have the descendants but to a
great degree a lot of them are mixed a
little bit with uh you know the whites.
If you look at the DNA, they say today
of the Arab world where there were
countless slaves, there is no African
DNA because they would either turn them
into Unix, okay, you know, take their
testicles away or just, you know,
outright kill them. But they would,
there was no mixture, no nothing. Um, so
that's why, you know, in other words, I
think you would, if you were a black
slave, you believe it or not, you would
better off in America than underra
Islam. Okay? Something maybe Malcolm X
should have been cognizant of. Um, so
anyway, this kind of thing goes on. But
first of all, it's in it's in their
Quran, you know, so it's legitimate. So
there's until today, it is legitimate,
which is why ISIS enslaved who they
enslaved. Okay? And and when did it end?
It ended when Western colonial powers
forced Islamic nations to stop. And
until today, it continues underground
wherever they can get away with it
because it's part of their teaching. And
yet you talk today to your average
Westerner who started slavery, who's the
bad guy? White people. Europeans,
they're the source of slavery even
though they're the ones who actually put
an end to slavery. So, this is the
topsyturvy world we're currently living
in.
>> Yeah, that's right. They they forced
them to stop slavery. But, as you said,
it still continues underground. But
essentially, the you know, the Brits
told the Saudis, "We're not going to
help you get your oil out of the ground
until you stop buying and selling human
beings." Okay, I'm going to ask you this
final question and then and then I'll
let you go. How do you think the history
of the Christian West, particularly the
downfall of the Ottoman Empire 100 years
ago, influences the way we learn
history? Have the winners taken their
success for granted and wrote out the
parts where they were the victims? So,
as you spoke earlier, you said the
Islamic world is actually very weak in
comparison to the West. And so do you
think that that contributes? Is it kind
of like an arrogance or a um
underestimating the enemy kind of thing
going on?
>> I would say definitely there was a lot
of arrogance in its origins you know
kind of seeing because a lot of this
comes from you know finally Europe
became ascendant and this is in the
colonial era which is basically around
1800 up until you know 19 whatever 30s4s
you can say 50s. Um, and what happens is
this is when Europe is powerful and it's
in Islamic lands. So, for some reason,
historians, this is all they think
about. I read a book and I've critiqued
it. It's called uh Jihad and Crusade.
The book's a thousand pages and the
subtitle is a thousand years of war
between Christians and Muslims. Some It
sounded like my book. That's why I had
to review it.
>> Guess what? It's a thousand pages. The
first 30 pages deal with the with the
centuries that I discussed, which is
from the beginning of the jihad in the
7th century until the colonial era, a
thousand years are just in 30 pages.
Then the rest of those 800 pages are all
about the colonial era. And they go into
extreme detail to show you how Muslims
are upset by that, how, you know, evil
the Europeans were. So definitely that's
part of the framework. You know people
their brain just goes to the colonial
era. I don't remember the other over
thousand years that happened which was
the exact opposite. Um but today I
believe it's just it's reached the point
where it's not it's intentional. Okay.
Now it's you know presenting the the
aggressors as the victims and the
victims as the aggressors. It's this is
obvious. It's it's too flagrant that it
can't be that people you know it's
intentional. A lot of it is coming from
Saudi Gulf money that goes to all these
ivy towers, ivy tow ivy universities.
Georgetown, Harvard, Princeton. Okay,
it's intentional. They're being bribed,
>> you know? So, yeah, it's because it's
just too extreme. It's too topsyturvy.
This can't be a coincidence anymore. And
especially when a person like me, I'm
the one who's sort of changing the
narrative and I'm being attacked. You
know, there was an incident a while
back. I was invited by the US Army War
College and CARE and all sorts of
leftist groups tried to shut it down
because um I'm speaking history and they
don't want history to come out. and
eventually they failed but they actually
the the war college did buckle until
people protested. Uh so you know there's
definitely a war against historical
truth.
>> Yes, you're absolutely correct. the
there's billions and billions of dollars
being pumped into American universities
from in fact when you take a look at um
the data on foreign funding you'll find
that
is number one by like by
by multitudes behind um
>> or ahead of the next one line which is
unfortunately China which is also bad
news. Um, so
>> why would why would these why would
authoritarian Islamic nations
spend millions to uh sponsor the liberal
arts in America?
>> Are they really so interested in making
or do they actually have an agenda and a
narrative that they're pushing on
people?
>> Yeah, of course. When I was speaking at
Harvard University, the building that I
was speaking in was called the Sharia
Institute of Harvard. So there's a photo
of me under this big beautiful plaque
that says Shereei Institute of Harvard.
It was absolutely ridiculous. Yeah. I
mean they're they're going to take the
money if it's being given to them, but
it's not being given to them without,
>> you know, expectations in return. And so
yeah, they we saw this on October 7th,
how successful their infiltration of our
universities over the past few decades,
how successful it's been. Um, and
unfortunate we we're now having to deal
with the consequences of that.
So, thank you so much, Raymond. You
really did an amazing job of bringing us
all the way from the very beginning of
Islam all the way up to today. Um my
next guest is going to be Rail Raza
who's going to pick it up from exactly
where you've left off here and she's
going to talk about um what happened in
the Muslim world now when we're well I
guess we should call it the the past
Christian world um when we're talking
about Muslims versus Islamists because
today we've been talking a lot about
political Islam and um these are now
referred to as Islamists and then
there's of Of course, Muslims who are
people who are born and raised and
believe all of these things, but some of
them don't necessarily um want to spread
Islam in the same way that Islamists do.
So, we have to be very careful to
recognize the difference and to not
confuse the two because people love to
say, well, this is, you know, religious
freedom and we have to let them be and
they be should be able to do whatever
they want when in actuality that's not
the truth at all. It's not religion.
It's not faith. This is a political
ideology and their goal is a global
caliphate. So, we'll get more on that um
from Rahil in the next episode. But
Raymond, before I let you go, I just
want to make sure that you have shared
everything with us that you wanted to
share with us that there isn't, you
know, something you wanted to talk about
that I didn't ask you about. Um any
parting words of wisdom to us or let
people know where they can follow you or
learn more from you. um tell us where
they can learn about you.
>> Sure. Uh my my one-stop site is my
website, raymondbraim.com.
R A Y M O N D I B R Ah i m.com. And also
I've started a YouTube channel. It's
rather modest, but I've started using
that medium to get across to Gen Z and
so forth because they don't want to read
and uh it's easier anyway. So you can
check me out on YouTube as well. Um, and
on my website you you there's links to
YouTube as well as my social media, most
of which I'm shadowbanned on. Um, except
I suppose Twitter. So, but thank you.
>> Thank you. Thank you so much. Yes. And
I've heard really great things about
your YouTube page. Lots of people have
been um promoting it and lots of people
have been recommending it. So, I'm going
to go check it out. Thank you so much
again for all of your knowledge, sharing
it with us today. We really appreciate
you so much. My pleasure, Yasm mean.
Thanks for having me and good luck with
the rest of your series.
>> Thank you so much and thank you everyone
for joining us. Bye everyone.
>> After hearing all that, you might be
left wondering, what can I do? How can I
help? Well, this is why I created a
nonprofit called Free Hearts, Free
Minds. We are the only organization
dedicated exclusively to helping these
freethinkers. We empower them with our
programs and supportive community,
lifting them up so they can heal, speak
out, and begin to make positive changes,
not just in their own lives, but within
the broader community around them. If
this is a cause that resonates with you
and you want to make a difference, one
way to do that is by donating to Free
Hearts, Free Minds. Because not enough
people care about this cause, we need
people like you to help fuel this
change. You can donate via our website
freeheartsfreeminds.com.
Thank you. Every dollar you donate makes
a difference.
[Music]